-"Sing 2" is coming out
next week.
I mean, we're excited
about this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It has such an amazing cast
and we wanted to do something
fun with the actors,
so we gave them a bunch
of weird phrases
and asked them
to sneak those phrases
into their interviews
as casually as possible.
No one knew we were doing this.
So, check it out.
It's time for "Drop It In."
-♪ Drop It In, Drop It In ♪
♪ D-D-D-D-Drop It In, yeah ♪
-Obviously, everyone's going
to watch "Sing 2" for Christmas.
How do you guys plan
on celebrating Christmas
this year?
-I'm just going to eat
a lot of food, I feel like,
'cause, you know...
[ Ding ]
...you know?
-That's right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Which of the following
is not a marsupial --
kangaroo, koala, or platypus?
-Koala.
-Platypus have no pouches.
They're the only
egg-laying mammal.
-Pouches, eggs...
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-I think it's also a movie
about...
overcoming your own
personal obstacles and --
I mean...
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How many "Sing" stories
do you want to tell?
Like have you thought
of what you would write
for "Sing 3" or "Sing 4"?
..."Sing 8," yeah...
-It'd be like the KIDZ BOP
version of movies!
-..."12." Yeah! I mean,
you'd skip 13 because of,
you know, bad vibes.
-Yeah, no, you can never
do that.
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But, no, I think, otherwise,
it could go on forever.
-So, this was obviously
like filming during the pand--
Did you guys get to get together
at any point?
-Ugh!
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're grape!
-That's sort of the fun
of show business
and the hard part is, you know,
you get ready and then there's
someone who can tell you no
and it's deflating, you know?
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
...and I think that the beauty
of this cast of characters is
they don't stop.
-In the film, Buster Moon has
to tell a little white lie.
I'm curious to know
if you've ever had to exaggerate
a special skill to either land
a role or get ahead.
-I never will tell a white lie.
And that's something I learned
when I once
put a balloon
inside of a microwave and...
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just have
one last thing to say.
Nunca es un buen idea poner
un globo en el microondo.
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's something that is
really important to remember.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you
for sharing that tip with us.